Guy Fieri is celebrity host of diners
drive-ins and dives and he's partnered
with the National Restaurant Association
Educational Foundation to raise money
for out-of-work restaurant workers to
date they've raised 21 million dollars
that's paid out in five hundred dollar
grants to donate visit our II our F dot
us guy joins us no guy I only wanted to
have you on for one reason and that is
how do you pronounce your last name P
Annie yeah in italian ER and i he's got
to pay a fee there's a fee eddie okay
because we I had people in my audience
who were saying that I was
mispronouncing it and my wife's Italian
so I said no I
it's Guy Fieri what do you have behind
you that that is that a man cave or your
office with what kind of stuff do you
have there and that's I mean it's
collecting it's all the stuff my wife
won't let me have in the kitchen and we
built this new house and she said you
have to finally move out of the kitchen
with all you crap and go sit in your go
sit in your own room so I look out the
patio the kitchens over to the
bobbleheads all that you know you look
at your collection
I should send you this new perfect
alright what's the best piece of sports
memorabilia you have a house pick the
computer up take you over there yeah
thanks sure yeah this is it right here
I think now I think this is it Kenny
Stabler oh that's great autograph Kenny
Stabler so Kenny have really good
buddies we met cuz I'm up here in Raider
country and we became really good
friends and spent several nights here at
the house while the old house and he was
the first one he came into my kitchen my
old house we're gonna
tear this out of the wall by the way and
he took this he took and wrote a Super
Bowl play on the wall in my kitchen and
then that subsequently led to everybody
that was famous sports star or now
musician cuz Sammy Hagar came in and
wrote lyrics on the wall and that really
made my wife happy Kentucky Derby but
all that but I'm Raider Nation so that
the kenny kenny pictures one of the best
who are some of the other sports stars
who have been at your place or you've
cooked for them you know music fan as
well but let's see here marshall i don't
know if you know Marcel Reece Marcel
played for played for the Raiders and
had quite a few quite a few Giants up
we're a little bit removed from things
we're about an hour and a half two hours
away from the city so we don't quite get
all of the you know we don't quite get
all the sports starts coming up this way
we usually have to travel travel down
there although my son would like to tell
you that we know that we've had we
should get curry up here every other
weekend but when you go on the road
though are you hanging who do you hang
out with my film crew I don't it goes
kind of kind of fast and furious you
know we go from I'll fly out of here we
look like I said Northern California
will fly out of here get in to see
Philadelphia I'll leave here before I
was just there with Michael Rubin at the
one of the last NBA games before this
all went down
but we flew out of here left at 4:00 in
the morning got to Philly I think you
know 11 o'clock in the afternoon shot
all day into the evening stay the night
shoot all day again and then fly home so
it's not like it was in the old days
where I'd go into town and shoot a
couple shows stick around for a day
shoot a couple shows together then I had
a little bit more play time now now the
schedule is not as permitting so I don't
get it but but I did have a great
Michael I did go to a great 76ers game
and sat on the floor and that's kind of
like when everything was
folding during this difficult time and a
matter of fact I was leaving from Philly
that night on my way to Hawaii to go
shoot more Triple D and well of course
that didn't happen so I've been home
since what was the car that you almost
picked to use on diners drive-ins and
dives besides the Camaro was there a
second choice so when we started the
show we did a pilot and the pilot was
like seven
we drove seven different cars and the
producer just went to car clubs and said
hey we're doing the show that's gonna
involve you know old cars and diners and
the school you know even before that we
really had designed with the shows like
so these car clubs would let me borrow
their car so I drove some really cool a
couple of really nice dodges I even did
drive a Ford I'm not a Ford guy I'm a
Chevy guy and when we got done doing the
show that we got picked up he says okay
so what car do you think we should drive
in the show and I said that's 67 Camaro
we drove that's you know that car you
ain't got that car so we used that car
for a couple years and then I finally
went and built the 68 that we use now
but no you had to be Chevy there was no
and it had to be convertible so we could
shoot yeah a lot of times the cameras in
the car with me and we need the light
and we need the height for the camera
inside is that your car yeah okay
how much it's it's a 68 rs/ss so rally
sports Super Sport it's got a it's got a
502 big-block Tremec five-speed is a
rotisserie car so it's it's fully gone
through my brother had a 69 rally sport
in the same color as yours so whenever I
see yours I always think of my brother's
red convertible rally sport and that was
a great car that was beautiful
no he sold it oh you know how many
people have walked up when I was in high
school I had no you end up getting the
car that you couldn't get in high school
it feels like right
you could have bought the car I mean it
to get the Super Sport package on a
Camaro was like because I have a couple
of chevelles also that are super sports
and the back he was the engine package
was it was a bigger deal but yeah I know
I see so many people that come up and
you can
we see it especially some of that the
old terms of look at it they'll kind of
give me this I had I went and the story
always kind of unfolds so he's a guy fee
at me diners drive-ins and dives explain
what you're doing with the restaurant
workers here this is all I've ever done
you know is do do rap and the TV thing
kind of came after that which I was I
really appreciate the opportunity but
I'm a chef I'm a cook restaurants at all
sides of it so when this happened when
we got this hit I knew with the tens of
thousands of restaurants that were being
closed we were gonna have ourselves into
a situation where we were going to just
have so many people without jobs and I'm
thinking like what can I do to help like
I mean go buy gift certificates which is
a great way to do it but I'm thinking
like on a national level so called the
National Restaurant Association
Educational Foundation because they're
the ones to take money in and then help
get money out they know how to how to
handle the deals then what if I start
sending out these videos to these
presidents of companies that interact
with restaurant restaurant business long
story short standing sending out videos
to you name it to Pepsi - ooh BRR each -
coke - you know - anybody that had some
direct connection and people started
sending money and I think just as last
night we were up to about twenty one
point five million twenty one point five
million one hundred percent of the
proceeds go directly to the employees
there's no administration fee or any of
that kind of stuff and the beauty of it
is is we've given out $500 grants and
the website if people want to check it
out to make a donation or to try to sign
up for one of the grants is our er f dot
us that's restaurant employee relief not
us but we'll make I mean listen it's a
terrible situation we're trying to make
some impact to just show that the people
that have been serving us for all these
years that the community is there and
trying to help serve them know it's
great stuff you know more serious
question who does your hair
well you you act like you don't know
because it's the same stylist you have
so I don't even know why does your wife
do it or do you do it or somebody else
well it's I don't know
the guys are supposed to ask I built a
career off great hair so if this comes
from a good place okay I'm here at my
house in the wine country and and we're
doing we're shooting diners drive-ins
and dives
in our kitchen or in our patio kitchen
and my sons are running the cameras my
youngest son's setting up GoPros my
oldest son is my co-host and got a my
producer and my wife's doing the makeup
and I said I thought it was a common
thing like well honey you know you just
touched me up a little bit cuz I look
that great yeah and I said I got [ __ ]
eyes and she's like it looks at me crazy
like you do your makeup she goes that's
not doing your makeup a learning curve
around here yeah my buddy might know is
a big stone it's okay yeah what's the
most overrated food facet I think
there's some good fast food don't get me
wrong and I think it's 4:00 in the
morning when you shouldn't be eating
there's there's you know fills a spot
but I think like eat a burger you know
if you're gonna eat a burger eat a
really righteous burger like eat a great
burger eat a burger they didn't freeze
the meat eat a burger that they
fresh-baked the buns you eat a burger
that they give it some some respect
insanitary but I think that this stuff
of just you know code anything in batter
and fry it don't get me wrong it has its
place but I think that if you're gonna
take on the calories and you're gonna
take on the carbs you're gonna go you
know maybe give yourself you know you're
gonna wait a slice of pizza
it's a really good pizza we got a lot of
great pizza in New Haven
not very far from here that like pizza
capital you don't think I all my all my
agents from WME you're from William
Morris Endeavor that all live up in that
area on a regular basis are explaining
to me how easy it is to get on the train
coming up the new it but no I had
cousins that lived in the area and I
remember being a kid from California
where we had just ours was just kind of
you know back in the 70s was done at
this
you know hippy Pizza where I lived at
least when I went there and they have
peaches this big the slices were you
know I say to my cousins like that's
everyday let's have pizza you know is
that good really what kind of workout
regimen do you cuz I watch you know you
see Friday it's like all-day all-night
diners drive-ins and dives and I'm going
you got to have a good workout regimen I
actually I'm a big outdoors guy so to me
going for a hike we have a big park
behind behind our house and then we have
a ranch 500 acre ranch so I spend a lot
of time hiking and mountain biking and
then when it rains I have my buddy might
got me a peloton treadmill which don't
ever say I mean I'd say something I'm
embarrassed so you can say it but I
gotta be honest it does push me you know
I don't necessarily listen to all the
classes and the people talking to me but
it does when the you know when there's
the schedule changes it does make you
push a little bit farther I haven't run
this much in my life I'm usually
inclined but how much will you gain if
you go out for a two-day trip like how
much I mean I look I watch when you take
the extra bite because of course you
want to be nice to the person that
you're in their kitchen you never go one
bite I'm done you always go do you
double down though I give you credit guy
you double down you go bite oh man
that's good you go one more time to give
them the ultimate compliment so I watch
the show but I don't have to watch all
of your show because I have a buddy in
mine named Millie and Daniel that he
texted me yesterday and said you're
gonna be on the show tomorrow aren't you
I go how do you know this he says oh
because I I took the tease there's some
analytics I so this buddy of mine Millie
might watch your show more than you
watch Triple D but you're right you got
the insight there I'll give you I'll
give you the credits on that okay
there's a difference between liking
something and loving something okay and
I never you'll never see it on the show
if I don't like it
I don't like it sometimes things get set
down we turn the camera off we just say
okay let's revisit this let's figure out
how we're gonna do this cuz this isn't
it I'm not setting a bunch of people
here to have this whatever we just I
don't last see what you do is walking up
to me going dude I went all the way
there and it sucked
which I bet people say and I say there's
to them I'm sorry I'm all over the board
but people had a lady come I'm doing a
demo I'm in I'm in DC I'm doing a demo
25 other people I'm up there I'm cooking
and I'm talking and we put the open mic
for people ask questions while I'm
cooking and this lady says hey I went to
this place in in Long Beach that you
went to and it was horrible what did you
have she said I had the pancakes with
the blueberry sauce and Waka moly burger
she goes oh yeah I had to anyway do you
have a bucket not I heard it you might
have a bucket underneath you that you
don't oh god no you eat you okay if I
take the bite if I take the bite I
finish the vodka
there's no I don't play the games I
don't that and I do know because like I
did some commercial that did some TV
some commercials for some restaurants
back in the day and we would be there
and they're like here's the spit bucket
I'm like just doesn't feel right you
know so any help no I've never been I'm
not gonna say the words I was just gonna
say but no I don't spit the food out so
it's what she's what'd you get he's the
mayor of flavortown how many people live
in flavortown by the way you know what I
meet citizens on a regular basis and
they send me wedding invitations and
graduation invitations and their kids
are the kids an Eagle Scout you know you
get all the same stuff there you have
the residents I see y'all the
I I see all the constituents that you
have there on our call good dudes by the
way which I always love the banter
dancers my favorite part as soon as I
see somebody else come on the street of
mic all right your cuffs Mac let's go
you know but you don't get that on
diners drive-ins and dives you can't
really have like you have you know have
a special guest sometimes but you need
to have somebody who really jabs you a
little bit I think 23 just graduated
from UNLV 1990 running revs thank you
that's right also but he's a top-notch
smartass you know he gets his little
jobs in here there and then the youngest
one rider who's 14 he's also starting to
take on the profession of being you know
of running his mouth which are both
funny I love mean listen that's I think
that's what keeps us going he keeps us
moving and keeps us sharp on our game
plus I have a whole crew I've got 20
people that shoot Triple D we have two
teams that are going you know all the
time and and they're you don't make a
you don't say a wrong line or drop
something on the floor or have you know
some mustard running down your cheek
without them gone you know it's great to
talk to you and continue to entertain us
and you're doing a great thing it's our
II our F dot us us raising 21 million
dollars that it will be paid out in
grants the National Restaurant
Association Educational Foundation
he's Guy Fieri and thank you guy we
appreciate your time
love the show thank you so much for
having me guys